Attacus atlas - one of the world's largest
moths.
Phyllium giganteum - ghost insects that look
like leaves.
Dynastes hercules - one of the biggest beetles
on earth.
They all make up just a small part of Adrian
Kozakiewicz's insect collection.
The young breeder has found millions of Internet
fans with his videos of bugs and spiders.
He says handling them is anything but icky.
“I've always had insects at home.
I'd catch them outside and then breed them.
It's part of me.
It's normal.”
The 20 year old has more than half a million
friends on facebook alone.
Many of his clips have gone viral.
They're now making him money.
Adrian can earn between 200 and 400 Euro per
clip for the rights.
The whackier the content, the more likely
it is to attract interest with agencies.
His biggest hits are his selfie videos.
“Normally it doesn't feel creepy.
The big ghost insects are the exceptions since
they have claws and like to latch on near
your eyes.
That's unpleasant.
What was also unpleasant was the world's biggest
snail.
I had it on my face and it was too slimy.”
Adrian shoots most of his videos in this
suburban neighborhood near Karlsruhe.
His parents' basement is kept at 24 degrees
Celsius - the preferred temperature of insects,
like the Goliath beetle.
It can grow to 11 centimeters and usually
lives in Africa.
Another highlight are his Australian
giant cockroaches.
A pair of them costs 250 euros.
Adrian owns 50 different insect and spider species.
Most are mantises.
“There are species like this one that are
perfectly adapted to dead leaves.
There are others that also imitate living
leaves or flowers.
There's a huge variety of types.
That's what's so fascinating about mantises.”
Adrian's insects are easy to care for.
Mantises are carnivores that eat live locusts
and spiders.
By contrast stick insects from Madagascar
get fresh blackberry leaves every three days.
Insects make up the largest group of fauna.
There are still many undiscovered species
living in rain forests.
Three to four times a year, Kozakiewicz goes
to Southeast Asia to get new species - although
none that are endangered.
Nonetheless animal right activists have complained
that he is misusing the insects as commodities and pets.
“Many people personify insects too much.
Insects have no consciousness.
All they sense are things like temperature,
humidity and the nutrients in the creatures they eat.
If you give them that, everything is fine.”
Adrian's social media success extends
beyond insect fanatics.
Recently, luxury Italian fashion designer
Gucci invited him to Florence to blog at an
exclusive fashion show.
These thorny devil stick insects are particularly
popular among Kozakiewicz's fans because they're
both rare AND creepy.
Every one of Adrian's videos increases interest
in insects as pets.
“I get more and more requests every year.
I've seen that more and more people are interested
in keeping insects, rather than, say, reptiles.
Insects and other invertebrates are a new
market.”
Insects - for many people they're a major
turn off.
But for Adrian Kozakiewicz, they're the most
exciting creatures in the world.